ساعات قبل احتفالها بذكرى تاسيسها رسميا
قبل
1541 عاما واجهت العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
اكبر هجوم روسي بالطائرات المسيره منذ
اندلاع الحرب وفق الجيش الاوكراني فان
هجوم فجر الاحد الاخير من ايار مايو
الحالي شنته تسعه وخمسون مسيره ايرانيه
الصنع من طراز شاهد واستهدف منشات عسكريه
وبنا تحتيه حيويه في مناطق متفرقه وقد
تمكنت الدفاعات الجويه من تدمير ثمانيه
وخمسين من تلك المسيرات المهاجمه
لكن التصدي للهجوم لم يحل دون وقوع خسائر
اذ بسبب تساقط حطام المسيرات وانفجار
مسيره واحده على الاقل قتل مدنيان وتضررت
مساكن ومنشات واندلعت حرائق استخدام الروس
هذا العدد القياسي من الطائرات المسيره
ناجم في تقدير القياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه عن مشكلات في ترسالتهم
الصاروخيه اما بالنسبه للرئيس زيلينسكي
فالعبره بالنهايات
شهدت ثياب العديد من الفضائع التي ارتكبها
الغزاه وقد نجت منها جميعا وسوف تنجو منها
ولن يكون اي غاز هنا وجميع مدننا وكل
اوكرانيا ستضع حد الاستبداد موسكو الذي
استعبد العديد من الشعوب المختلفه لفتره
طويله جدا روسيا لن تنقذها طائره شاهد او
اي وسيله اخرى من وسائل الارهاب لان القوه
في الناس فهي موجوده في المدن انها الحياه
مناطق كثيره حول دونيسك اصبحت ركاما
فالروس على حد قول ضباط في الجيش
الاوكراني عندما لا يتمكنون من الاستيلاء
على منطقه
يدمرونها بالمدفعيه مثل ما فعلوا في
باخموت ومارينكا وغيرهما ومع ذلك لا مامن
للاليات الروسيه من المسيرات الاوكرانيه
المفخخه
ومع اعلان كيف ان هجومها المضاد قد بدا
فعلا في بعض الجبهات وموافقه الغرب على
تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات حربيه واسلحه
متطوره يتصاعد غضب موسكو المتحدث باسم
الكريم
قال ان حربا تخاض ضد روسيا على كل الجبهات
اقتصاديا ودبلوماسيا وماليا لكن اهداف
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا لم تتغير وينبغي تحقيقها
تاكيدا لذلك ربما وتحديا للتكنولوجيا
العسكريه الغربيه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان انظمه دفاعها الجوي اسقطت
ثلاثه صواريخ ستورم شادو البريطانيه وسته
صواريخ هي مارس الامريكيه خلال يوم واحد
في المعارك الدائره شرقيه اوكرانيا